Good morning everyone. I'm Raini
Ramolingum and I lead the enterprise
security team at Snowflake. Um wanted to
thank Gaddy and the team at Gnostic for
putting this conference together and all
of you for this great community that has
come together um to discuss the
challenges that we have in AI security.
I want to start off with by by making an
quick observation. Enterprise security
for decades assumed that the execution
in the enterprise is predefined or
deterministic.
So we had identities authenticating. We
had you know systems and workflows exe
executing predefined logic and
automation existed but that was based on
what humans defined and systems just
executed it. And today a AI it's
fundamentally different.
We are deploying systems that now make
decisions at runtime and invoke actions
from the endpoint to the cloud to SAS
and and blurring boundaries. And this is
basically moved from
deterministic action to making context
aware actions in in real time that are
not controlled by humans.
So how do we govern
this new ecosystem?
The traditional governance models don't
don't work anymore and governance has to
become dynamic and evolve. I'd like to
quote our CESO Brad Jones um who said
governing AI at a company like Snowflake
where the AI data cloud is like laying
tracks in front of a running train. And
our challenge was to lay those tracks
and not slow down the running train. How
do you achieve that? So we had to come
up with a governance model that
you know helped us to make decisions
really quickly and enable innovation and
but safely and securely. So I'll walk
you through the governance model we
adopted to enable this.
So why is AI governance fundamentally
different? First, AI tool adoption does
not wait for review cycles and it does
not follow the pace that you know uh
that we see in the traditional
enterprises. It begins with engineers
experimenting with product teams trying
to integrate with um uh solution
engineers trying to showcase and
business teams trying to uh increase
their productivity using AI. So we had
to come up with processes that evolved
at that speed. feature velocity and and
second feature velocity outpaces um you
know any kind of feature releases. AI
vendors are releasing features
weekly and sometimes few times a week
and therefore our security processes had
to become dynamic. Third, most
importantly AI burs the boundary. We
used to have you know control planes
that was strictly dedicated to endpoint
or network or cloud or SAS. And today
with AI one prompt can trigger an action
at an endpoint. It can read make system
calls make read file read or write files
on the endpoint. It can make outbound
network egress or it can invoke um APIs
reaching out to SAS platforms. And
therefore the control plane has to be
across all of these domains and cannot
be just static control planes. The risk
again is once again is no longer static
because the execution model has now be
turned from one of deterministic to
non-deterministic
and it had the execution boundary has
significantly expanded and therefore in
order to be able to govern this AI we
need to evolve our governance model at
the same velocity at which the
technology is evolving.
So we realized early that in order to
make
uh you know in order to be our
governance model to be dynamic we needed
to have a structure that allowed us to
make quick decisions. So we formed an
enterprise steering committee with with
uh uh you know members from security,
IT, legal, privacy, a IML, data
engineering and procurement teams and we
with the and and all of these members
came together because they had the
ability to see the uh AI adoption across
the enterprise and AI usage patterns.
And so with those we identified the
risks that we saw across this US usage
patterns and adoption and we came up
with mitigation controls and whether it
be technical controls, process controls
or contractual protections
and then as a next step we bubble that
up to our executive leadership teams and
in in engineering, product management,
sales, customer experience, IT etc. And
these are the teams that were innovating
at speed with the AI technology. And so
this helped us to surface the risk up to
the executive leadership and make risk
informed decisions that align with our
leadership's risk appetite because at
Snowflake
you know engineering innovation is is an
engineering at speed is our is our is in
our DNA and
enabling or disabling AI was not a
security decision.
It is actually a business decision and
it's not a security trade-off. It's a
business trade-off. So having our
executive leadership weigh in and and
making decisions aligned with the risk
appetite of the business helped us
actually get that alignment as well as
any cultural change that was required in
the environment.
So we shifted from reactive approvals to
proactive risk ownership. And truly this
structure was the one that helped us
make decisions much faster.
You cannot govern what you cannot see.
So it's getting visibility into
enterprise AI usage and adoption is
critical in order to be able to govern.
So we uh looked at four pathways in
order to get visibility. First is our
procurement process and we already had a
pretty mature process and we built AI
oversight into that and we looked at uh
we looked we we uh rationalized the
products not based on features and we
not only did a security risk review but
we also looked at whether the tool had
redundant capabilities. So what that
helped us do is eliminate tools which
had overlapping capabilities and uh
which will not only just reduced our uh
operational overhead but also uh helped
us eliminate unnecessary attack
surfaces.
Next we um we all know that AI does not
come just in a new product. It is
turning on AI features in existing
products. So we gated those uh turning
on new features through through security
reviews. We required people to go
through security reviews in order to
enable AI features and existing tools
and platforms.
And uh third most importantly we
actually did an active discovery for AI
artifacts and interactions across the
enterprise. And being the AI data cloud,
we have we our security lake lives in
our own platform. And with the AI
capabilities that we have on our
platform, we were able to quickly get
insights um based on the telemetry that
we had on the endpoint data uh network
um uh cloud and SAS environments. We
were able to identify AI artifacts um
such as MCP components, models, agents,
and those interactions.
Uh last but not the least, we constantly
partnered and had discussions with our
uh peers in the business units and this
is critical. You need to have security
partners in in all business units that
you con you know you you keep in touch
with so you're aware of uh get in early
insights into a AI adoption in those
business units and that helps us make
informed decisions.
So with that visibility and that
governance structure we were actually
able to uh effect a cultural change when
we were able to enable AI adoption
responsibly.
So first we establish enterprise
guardrails. Um so we uh you know
deployed endpoint network and DLP
controls that were aligned to AI usage
patterns.
And the goal here was simple. Just
allowed approved use cases and approved
tools and then maintained consistent
enforcement. Then we um with the
visibility that we had, we basically um
identified tools that were broadly used
in the organization and made a conscious
decision to procure some of those tools
so that we can um manage them
effectively. And in some cases we
decided that some of the tools were
risky and did uh and um you know guided
our users towards approved alternatives
in the enterprise.
And last lastly we had um and again
snowflake is um is a place where uh
there is a lot of AI experimentation
happening and so when we needed to
provide um when AI experimentation
needed to happen, we resorted our core
operating principle was provide isolated
environments with test tenants and
synthetic data and where that was not
possible and you know some use cases is
where we they needed to have production
adjacent environments. We came up with
what is called an responsible AI
experimentation framework which is
setting clear accountability for the
experimentation teams and security and
IT and additional review processes and
preventive and detective controls.
So I'll I'll you know that was our
governance structure and how we set
about doing um you know respond securely
enabling AI in the enterprise. I want to
talk a little bit more into how we
actually um deployed Genai tools in our
enterprise.
So we all know that um the genai tools
evolve quickly and there are features
releasing
you know weekly or few times a week but
the enterprise level controls in those
tools are do not evolve at the same
speed as features. So we had to do um
feature-based risk assessment rather
than broad in enablement of a tool with
all its features. So when we looked at
the features, we looked at what
capabilities were there in the
enterprise plane control plane um to be
able to effectively control um data
exfiltration or limit the um limit the
in the the risk from integrations around
that platform. So this would include
things like did we did we have the
ability to uh manage allow lists or deny
lists within the platform for MCP or
tools or uh web fetches or you know web
search and things like that.
So what we did was we enabled the
features that were less risky and we
that that we felt comfortable enabling
with the controls that were already
available in the enterprise and we gated
the features which were not um we didn't
have which we felt were not um did not
have sufficient controls natively in the
product. So this began a conversation
with our vendors. So we engaged actively
with our AI tool vendors and uh made
feature requests to make those
enhancements.
Coding agents and I know all of us here
in the room you know encountered this in
our uh enterprises. coding agents
potentially shift the uh you know
significantly shift the threat model in
the enterprise and this is the perfect
example of how the attack surface in the
enterprise expands
um with AI and how you know the uh whole
execution model has shifted from
predetermined action to real time
execution contextbased execution with
expanded boundaries and this coding
agent is a perfect example for that. So
we have the risk from autonomous code
execution
that can happen. uh you know these
coding agents don't just write code
right they execute um system level calls
they make file system reads or they are
integrating with uh APIs
and which all of which amplifies the
remote code execution uh amplific risk
and there are most of these come with
embedded browser components which are
bypassing standard controls. So we had
to come up with um with with
we had to come up with solutions in
order to restrict and in in order to
address that risk.
And again the same problem as the uh
genai tools. We don't have
enterprisegrade controls that uh in in
most of these coding agents today and or
they're still trying to they're still in
the process of maturing and there is
rapid u uh release velocity. So this is
coding agent is is not just another
development tool and we had to work
closely again with the vendor to get the
features released that um that we
required.
We had a structured
um assessment for the agentic tools. It
followed the same pattern as what we did
for the genai tools. We we assessed all
of the execution surfaces whether it was
a command line or desktop and we did the
same feature-based risk impact and we
the most importantly
one of the most important things at an
engineering company like Snowflake is we
needed to make sure that we did not
develop the work developer productivity
and therefore we had to come up when we
made these risk assessments and came up
with mitigation
We had to keep that in mind front and
center and aligned with the risk
appetite of our executive leadership. So
it was um we had to you know come up
with a set of controls that worked for
us that did not impact developer
productivity while un enabling us to use
the features securely.
So what we did is we en enabled
enterprise um guardrails. We tried to
constrain the uh tools within our
enterprise tenant. We we established
hardened configuration
for this and most of you know that
coding the um the the enterprise control
plane in these coding agents do not
provide a very uh secure set of a robust
set of controls in order to be
effectively enforce immutable
configuration at the endpoint. So we had
to deise endpoint. We had to do come up
with controls using our existing IT and
um uh security tool set to constrain the
to to m try and maintain this immutable
config configuration at the end points
and uh we and we had to come up with
again you we used our existing uh IT and
security tool tool set to secure both
the manual as well as the automated
browser pathways which are huge um which
huge risk.
um in terms of um you know data
excfiltration or prompt injection.
And when it came to restriction of
higher autonomy modes, we approached it
really carefully. Um again trying to do
what we could and limiting the um
limiting this to uh we looked at the
user groups and risk profiles and we
kind of you know enabled those features
based on the risk profile of the users
and we are still we work continue to
work with vendors because it is a lot of
these enterprise control planes for
these uh coding agents do not have like
scheme based
uh enablement of features. So um you
know those were requests that we put
into the vendors in order to help us uh
be able to selectively deploy certain
certain features for certain groups of
users or constrain the high-risk
features just to select groups of users
and to even be able to test them before
deployment.
Um and again approved integrations and
capability surfaces when you come to uh
like being able to allow MCP tool MCP
servers or tools um or being able to
restrain the web search to certain
domains uh allowed domains and maintain
the same configuration as the enterprise
um that's in place in the in the rest of
the enterprise.
We had to um we had to come up with um
very um you know we had to come up with
innovative ways of using our um existing
tool set and where uh we were stretched
we constantly worked with our vendors to
um to for feature enhancements in the
product. So, and we've se seen the
vendors actually respond to these
feature requests and we've seen
significant uh improvements in the last
few months.
So, what enables AI to scale
responsibly? I think fundamental thing
uh and then these are the lessons
learned from our journey. It is
fundamentally exe executive sponsorship
drives alignment. So it is really
important for um you know to be able to
update your leadership about the risks
with with data like you with the
visibility you get you u provide you
provide an update to your leadership and
you need to be able to make informed
decisions with that sponsorship
and shared ownership scales better than
central control. So we um it it's really
important to have that crossf functional
alignment and the exi steering committee
really helped us there. We um that what
is critical is that cross functional
alignment as well as a top-down um you
know alignment on risk is is what helped
us keep our governance model dynamic.
Visibility is crucial in order to be
able to govern. So whatever uh pathways
you have in your environment to get that
visibility, make sure um that you know
you are leveraging that in order to uh
get the data that you need to uh be able
to share u that with your um cross
functional teams and executive teams.
And the most important thing is um last
um you know I would say that it it's
really important to focus on
constraining the execution authority
because you cannot stop the innovation
you cannot stop AI adoption in the
enterprise because uh if you did it'll
go around you so and if you and if the
other thing is it is going to impact
your business. So it is really important
to focus on constraining what the
execution authority of the AI not
restraining AI completely and governance
must evolve at the same velocity as AI
and you need to make sure that your
processes whether it is review processes
or your uh decision processes are able
are dynamic and evolving at the same
pace of the technology. So AI governance
is not a roadblock to innovation. It
really is the foundation to enable um
innovation securely and responsibly.
Thank you.
>> Okay. Thanks very much. Let's get some
questions.
Chase, go ahead. Come on up.
>> Uh thank you very much for a good talk.
Uh couple of questions. And so when you
talk about these um enterprise uh
governance code agents, I'm thinking in
terms of some agents that could
potentially
uh place uh trades for in 45 minutes
they can lose half a million bucks or
$500 million depending on the what
happened with night. Are are those the
kind of things that you are trying to
avoid because that could be a lot more
and if so how exactly are you
controlling it? So um as I said we um
you know based on our discovery we see
what coding agents are deployed across
our enterprise
and we um
ensure that we only allow the coding
agents that are approved in the
enterprise and we um we performed risk
assessment for those coding agents that
are approved in the enterprise and so we
steer our users towards the approved
platforms
>> but that's manual right? That's going to
be somewhat slower than uh the speed of
AI.
>> So it it it is not so it it it is
you it it it is something that is your
AI risk is dynamic and it is
continuously evolving, right? So you
need to your p the pace at which you
perform your discovery the pace at which
you you know uh surface up any anomalies
or risks to your cross functional team
and and your leadership needs to be
dynamic. So you need to be having these
conversations on a weekly or sometimes
on a daily basis about what you see
across the enterprise and make those
decisions. If you need to shut something
down, you need to be able to get, you
know, quick alignment and and shut it
down.
>> Sure.
>> One more question.
>> Hi, thank you. Um, what technical
controls have you put in place to
actually constrain that execution
authority that you mentioned in the last
slide?
So it depends really on the on the tool
on the coding agent and what controls
are available within um the the a the
agent's control plane itself. Um so like
um for example what we did for the
browser execution pathways. So there
there could be automated or they could
be um uh manual execution. So for the
for the automated ones we actually
restrain them just to our internal
domains and for the um uh for the uh
manual browser pathways we basically
ensure use using our other EDR tools we
constrain or constrain them to just to
the same to match what we had for the
rest of the enterprise.
So that's just one example. Yeah.